es scheint so als würde deutschlands
recht breites verständnis für diese
neuen maßnahmen haben die nun an diesem
heutigen tage auch für das ganze land
bald gelten können
einer der sich aber durchaus schwer tut
mit der beschränkung unserer freiheit
ist mein kollege alexander von schönburg
der mir jetzt zugeschaltet ist halo
alexander hallo eigentlich klingt es
doch ganz sinnvoll zu sagen wir bleiben
alle zuhause das virus breitet sich so
nicht weiter aus was kann man dagegen
haben
also ich kann kaum glauben dass ich der
einzige bin der bei solchen bildern oder
seiner schilderung nicht in absolute
empörung empfinden es ist ja nicht nur
wie du gerade gesagt hast dass es nicht
sein kann dass man des landes verwiesen
indem angemeldet ist und wo man das
eigentum wird immer auch streitig
gemacht
der minister zeige ganz einfach das
einfach so ist das grundrecht auf
eigentum plötzlich nicht mehr gelten
also diese diese leichtfertigkeit mit
der unrechte einfach so per federstrich
außer kraft gesetzt werden und bild
gesetzt werden also ich finde das unheil
nicht ich bin nicht allein auf einmal
scheint es zumindest ein großes
verständnis dafür zu geben dass man zu
hause bleiben muss aber der punkt wie
weit liefern wir uns eigentlich
staatlichen anordnungen die jetzt auch
einfach so durchgesetzt werden oder
bürger großartig zu befragen
es ist schon etwas was vielleicht auch
dem ein oder anderen gedanken machen
könnte was stört sich daran am meisten
vertraute dem staat nicht mehr also der
servicemann etwas sehr interessantes
geschrieben hat gesagt es ist jetzt nun
an der zeit nicht nur seine gesundheit
sondern auch seine freiheit zu
verteidigen
und ich glaube dieser moment ist
gekommen also mir läuft es da kalt den
rücken runter wenn ich sehe wie wenig
solche maßnahmen wie gerade geschildert
bei domenica oder wenn wir jetzt dieses
auto durch münchen fahren sehen also mir
läuft sagt kalt den rücken und dann bin
ich es kann nicht sein dass ich da
alleine bin ich finde ich habe auch noch
ein politiker gehört der mir das jetzt
im schlüssig erklärt hat also ich kenne
ich lasse mich gerne eines besseren
belehren aber mir hat noch kein
politiker erklärt auf welcher
rechtsgrundlage das stattfindet ich höre
immer achten zu § 28
infektionsschutzgesetz aber soweit ich
weiß da kann so etwas nur örtlich vom
zuständigen ordnungsamt im zusammenhang
mit dem gesundheitsamt angeordnet werden
also rein zeitlich begrenzt und vor
allem örtlich begrenzt die politiker
reden immer von landesweiter oder oder
gar bundesweite ausgangssperre
es gibt dafür überhaupt keinen
paragrafen dass wir das spiel
grundsätzlich artikel 2 des
grundgesetzes der man sieht ja schon an
der reihenfolge ziemlich gleichschnell
nach der nach dem artikel 1 von artikel
2 garantiert mir die freien fall ging
der persönlichen ist stimmt das
infektionsschutzgesetz § 28 kann das
zeitlich begrenzt wirklich bist du
beseitigen bis zur einrichtung von
schutzmaßnahmen dies wörtlich heißt
haben dieses grundrecht eingeschränkt
werden aber es gibt überhaupt keine
rechtsgrundlage so etwas bundesweit oder
landesweit zu machen was mich ehrlich
gesagt noch mehr stört als das cabrio
das dass mir kein politiker erklärt
wenigstens nicht stört daran dass der
deutsche bundestag darüber nicht
dementiert dass der deutsche bundestag
vertreten sozusagen unser souverän ist
wenn der deutsche bundestag ist nun
verabschiedet für eingesetzt dann muss
ich nicht damit abfinden habe ich
gewählt habe ich das kann mir doch jetzt
irgend ein nicht gewählter virologe
jetzt plötzlich sehen ich finde diese
leichtfertigkeiten den wir das nicht
einmal infrage stellen nicht total
beunruhigend gesagt
wege braucht um gewisse dinge schnell
durchzusetzen so zumindest der weg der
deutschland da gerade geht was wäre denn
dein gegenvorschlag tatsache ist ja ist
bleiben offenbar nicht genug menschen zu
hause die infektionsketten können nicht
mehr durchbrochen werden unsere
krankenhäuser werden bald überfüllt
werden und die bloße aufforderung bitte
bleibt zuhause bitte watt abstand hat
bisher nicht geholfen was wäre also dein
gegenvorschlag sehe ich vollkommen
anders wenn ich durch die stellten sie
eine höchst diszipliniert verhalten des
bevölkerung sämtliche geschäfte sind
geschlossen ist ein traum doch menschen
von 8 m
was mich daran geradezu bringt das ist
dazu dass das noch dazu gejubelt wird
sieht viele ich finde es nicht
ich finde es wir sind es schuldig
wenigstens in solchen situationen auch
die entscheidungen der der der der
entscheidungsträger in frage zu stellen
wenn das nicht einfach so hinnehmen
erwarten wir wenigstens eine öffentliche
diskussion ich möchte noch etwas sagen
ich hab mal ein buch geschrieben dass
kein mensch interessiert weil die bücher
jetzt auch eingestellt denn es gibt gar
nichts mehr unser land kulturell
wirtschaftlich komplett zum stillstand
in dem buch das nun eingestampft wird
oder was auch immer ausgeliefert wird es
gibt ja eine buchhandlung entsteht wer
meint es bräuchte eine expertin diktatur
vor
für die zeit der krise im sei gesagt
dass wenn die demokratie erst einmal
geschlossen ist wie dann herrschenden
immer eine gewisse krise finden werden
erst nur während geht und er mein freund
nun mal herr professor unternehmens hat
in der financial times gestern ein sehr
interessantes gedankenexperiment
angestellt hat gesagt was wäre denn wenn
die wir den ist eine hypothetische
regierung geht wie uns allen befiehlt
armbänder zu tragen die die temperatur
messen und unseren gesundheitszustand an
die an eine zentrale melden könnten
würden wären wir beinahe wären wir mit
so einer maßnahme ein vermutlich wenn es
um die gesundheit gehe aber muss sich
mal vorstellen was für ein durchgriff
geschaffen die eine regierung weiß nicht
nur wo ich mich aufhalte
wenn man wie ich mich zum beispiel fühle
und solche maßnahmen
sind ja schon in kraft ist die
bundesregierung empfängt sämtliche daten
die von der telekom ausgeliefert werden
wo ich mich aufhalte
das heißt wenn ich morgen entpacken
irgendwie vernünftig verhalten gehen
einigen einen einsamen wald gemacht wird
ein spaziergang
dann sieht dass die regierung und kann
aufgrund dieser information vielleicht
verfügen dass es verboten ist
in den wald zu gehen es kann doch nicht
das kann doch wenigstens muss das doch
wenigstens im buch ist ein burkhard
hirsch wo ist ein gerhart baum wenn man
ihn braucht prozent die grünen wo sind
die liberalen die so etwas wenigstens in
frage stellen oder mehr die
rechtsgrundlage dessen erklären wo ist
der daten stattfindet sehen nur google
und alle machen mit aufgeheizt konnte
von 5 von oben was ist denn in der
nächsten krise ich bin überzeugt dass
wir diese meistern werden
aber es ist immer der nächsten viel was
sagt denn wenn ein irgendwelchen
wissenschaft mehr sagen aus welchen
gründen auch immer wir müssen alle zu
hause bleiben müssen sämtliche
wirtschaft aktivitäten einstellen und
dann machen wir das nächste mal gang
genau so und wie lange soll das ganze
dauern sodass jetzt vier wochen dauern
würde sieht es bei monate dauern was zu
den gewinnen spray drei monaten wieder
infektionszahlen gibt werden die dann
wieder alles von vorne schließen werden
da sie zwei jahre machen wer erklärten
zwar ja ich sehe du fühlst dich dem
start ziemlich ausgeliefert alexander
vielen dank dass du uns hier deine
meinung kund getan hast ich verspreche
dir ich kaufe oder ein buch auch wenn es
eingestampft wird oder gar nicht erst
erscheint vielen dank